a lot of you have been requesting for my
meal prep video what do I eat in a
typical day before I get started if you
haven't yet subscribed to my YouTube
channel be sure to hit the subscribe
button and turn on your notification so
that you will get notified every time I
share a new workout video recipes or
even fitness tips for those of you who
have no clue on what meal prepping is
how or where to start
be sure to check out my last video where
I shared with you at the beginners guide
to start meal prepping it is really
simple anybody and everybody can and
should do it to live better and also to
eat healthier right what do I eat here
are all the ingredients I'll be cooking
two meal prep for the next three days
for breakfast I'm making overnight oats
lunch will be tuna salad dinner is
roasted fish with vegetables and I'm
having a banana walnut muffins as my
snacks I like to prep my meals for up to
three days to keep them fresh some
people like to prep for the entire week
that really depends on your schedule
this entire process took me less than
two hours and remember it is all about
being efficient so we're going to start
by prepping meals that would take the
longest to cook the first dish is dinner
baked fish with vegetables as that will
take the longest to cook
what I have are 500 grams of frozen
tilapia you can use any other fish on
meat of your choice about two carrots
one red bell pepper one head broccoli
one sweet potato one red onion six
garlic cloves 1 tablespoon of olive oil
1 tablespoon of apple cider vinegar
quarter teaspoon of mixed herbs and salt
and pepper to taste
to save time start by preheating the
oven to 220 degrees Celsius always begin
by prepping all your ingredients so I'm
going to wash and chop all my vegetables
carrots bell pepper broccoli soup potato
onion and garlic next I'm marinating my
fish with olive oil mixed herbs and salt
and pepper and let's set it aside then
grab a baking dish and make a bed for
the fish by arranging all the chopped up
vegetables
I'm also going to season my vegetables
with some olive oil apple cider vinegar
mixed herbs and also salt and pepper
then simply arrange the marinated fish
on top of the vegetables and wrap the
baking dish with aluminum foil I want to
bake this in the oven for 30 minutes or
until the vegetables are tender so while
waiting for dinner to cook in the oven
I'll move on and prep my snack banana
walnut muffins as that will also take
time to cook in the oven so in a large
bowl mash 2 large bananas then whisk in
2 eggs 1/2 a cup of yogurt and about 2
tablespoons of honey still until well
combined and set aside blend about 1 and
a half cups of rolled oats until fine
now in a separate bowl mix in oats 1
teaspoon of baking soda cut a cup of
crushed walnuts and about 2 tablespoons
of cranberries now we're going to
combine the wet and dry ingredients
together keep mixing until you get an
even better then divide equally into 12
cupcake liners I've also topped it up
with some oats and also walnuts by the
time the muffins are ready to go into
the oven my baked fish and vegetables
should be done so I'm going to grab my
fish out of the oven and allow it to
cool down and bake my muffins for 15
minutes until the muffins are cooked
through while the muffins are baking in
the oven let's move on and prep lunch
really simple tuna salad so in a bowl
combine two kinds of tuna chunks cut a
cup of plain yogurt half a tablespoon of
lemon juice 1 tablespoon of cranberries
and some salt and pepper to taste I'm
going to fill half of each container
with my favorite vegetables and remember
to be generous so I've got spinach
cherry tomatoes carrots and red bell
peppers I like to keep my tuna mixtures
separate from the salad just to keep the
ingredients fresh and when you're ready
to eat simply chop the tuna onto the
salad or you can even make yourself a
tuna sandwich or a wrap and the final
meal to prep is breakfast overnight oats
so in a large bowl I'm combining one and
a half cups of rolled oats with two
tablespoons of chia seeds
two tablespoons of dried cranberries one
and a half cups of any milk of your
choice three teaspoons of honey and two
tablespoons of peanut butter just stir
all the ingredients until they are well
combined then I'm going to divide the
odd mixture equally into three jars and
refrigerate them overnight the next
morning top it up with your favorite
fruits and breakfast is served I'm also
going to portion out my trail mix into
three separate containers for each day
so it's a quarter cup of nuts seeds and
dried fruits right the muffins should be
done
get them out and allow them to cool down
all I'm left to do now is assemble all
the ingredients into their own
containers so for my dinner place the
vegetables at the bottom of the
containers and top it up with the fish
for lunch I'm going to add two banana
walnut muffins into my containers to
have them as my snack and we're done the
entire process took me less than two
hours remember keep it simple
the more you mill prep are the quicker
and more efficient you will become added
depending on your activity level and
physique you would want to increase the
portion and calories accordingly
remember that a nutrition makes up 80%
of your success so prioritize your meals
stay active and sleep well I can assure
you you will feel better live better
look really good and you will really
live a much healthier life remember that
the long-term benefits of meal prepping
are so worth the effort it's only four
hours in a week is that too demanding is
that too time-consuming
are you worried let me know in the
comments below what other meal prep
methods do you use what do you like to
prep for your meals I want to know so
share it on okay share this video on
like this video motivate someone to
start meal prepping and also remember to
subscribe to my youtube channel
turn on your notification button so that
you will get notified for every new
video all the best and Stan your
prepping